[Music]
so yeah thanks for talking with us so we
found out a few weeks ago that a
extended relative has been
sexually molesting our six-year-old
daughter we
involve the authorities at that point
and there has been some negative
feedback from other family members on
that yeah we'll screw them they don't
get a vote
[Music]
what up what up this is john with dr
john dolone show
so happy that you are with us
talking about mental health
relationships
i don't know
education school what's going on
whatever's going on in your life that
involves people that's what we're gonna
talk about uh if you want to be on the
show give me a shout 1-844-693-3291
it's
1-844-693-3291 or you can go to
johndaloni.com
ask two big deals today number one
james is out and will rudder the guru is
driving
and here's the here's the thing
so james and is an incredible guitarist
and
he mostly plays fenders
here's the thing james and i were in in
one of the greatest metal bands of all
time for one show and he played a fender
though i mean at gibson the whole show
and it made everything i mean it was
incredible it changed him he now he
doesn't shave at all he bathes rarely
it's a whole thing he wears leather
pants around the office it's awesome
and then there's will
there's will
will is a better guitar player than me
by like a thousand percent can't even
hold a candle here's the problem will
loves creed
and he plays a paul reed smith
and if that's inside baseball for you
folks who don't play guitar just google
it in fact don't don't you don't want
that in your search engine because
you'll start getting things like ads for
i don't know
weird shoes and
hyundai's and stuff like that it's a
whole it's a whole it's a whole
underworld just don't become a paul reed
smith person
and i also say that out of jealousy
because we'll just
he's just better than me i have to just
own that here's the second thing
so kelly
is so great
yesterday i'm minding my own dad
business sitting in my own dad chair uh
she look we got chairs and it's awesome
i said so
we got like uh chairs that like that are
comfortable to sit in not just like
wooden chairs we've never had those in
our house
and uh
josephine comes in my daughter's six
and here's a direct quote
dad
mind you like sunshine's out it's like 5
30 or 6 o'clock in the evening
she just sticks her head out of my
bedroom
dad have you ever seen mom naked
and i thought to myself i guess we're
doing this now and i was like yes
i have
to which she her face looks like i just
grew 11 heads and a couple of arms
it was stunning
and the only natural answer question
that she could follow up with was
has she seen you naked
i was like
oh man
no your mom actually closes her right no
i did i was like yeah she has
and just to see this confusion slash
dismay slash
cackling giggling that went on it wasn't
giggling it was like
it was like the joker when she was a
child if he was a woman and was a child
the dismay and the uh
so then she just closed the door and i
thought yes because i knew my wife was
in there and she was gonna finish the
rest of that train of thought with her
which was super awesome
didn't see that one coming
that's all i have to say about that
let's go to jenny in oregon what's up
jenny
hey john how's it going i'm i'm
recovering
and you sounds like it
oh i haven't had those questions yet
mine's only nine months old so
i'll get there listen it's so great i
wish you'd seen it
in our house we talked about that all
the time i guess you just never put five
and five together
and anyway the follow-up question was do
y'all just stare at each other it was a
whole i mean she just went down the
rabbit hole for a minute so anyway well
good luck with that enjoy these these
silent years while you have them
right
so what's up well my question my
question for you today
uh my husband and i are actually
expecting our second in october congrats
thank you um
and we're both struggling with a little
bit of gender disappointment we we both
were really hoping for a little girl
and while we are excited we are having
another little boy and so i'm trying to
really figure out how to
navigate that both my husband and i
unfortunately he's at work right now so
i'm kind of speaking for the both of us
as far as that goes but we're just
we're needing some help because we're
really kind of struggling emotionally so
um this sounds deeper than just
traditional disappointment or just
bummed out so
it sounds like there's another layer to
this talk to me about that
oh i'm sure there probably is
so we found that last
let's see last monday we found out we
were having a little boy and i slept on
it and i did
i'm actually better with it and i'm
really starting to lean more towards
excitement and the idea that our kids
are going to be 15 months apart so
they'll have you know they'll be little
brothers they'll be able to wrestle
together play that kind of thing and
there's going to be pee everywhere
there is everywhere you know fantastic
that's right okay so you you you
you just described the perfect
we were disappointed our hearts kind of
dropped and at the same time
no it's gonna be amazing right so
and then you've begun to actually create
a new picture of what this is gonna look
like
right so i have um and i'm starting to
you know but it it creeps the
disappointment for me personally creeps
back up a little bit
when
like i'm doing some grocery shopping or
i'm at walmart grabbing whatever
and i see a little dress or i see
something that's more specific to a
little girl moment that at least i know
with this second little
we're not gonna get the original plan
was to
hard stop it two and be done yeah have
seven
i have seven
yeah
uh yeah let's go with a no on that one
okay so
two in is your husband taking this hard
he is and i'm a little more concerned on
his end of things than i
probably should be just because i love
him and i want him to open up and i want
him to
to have to feel like he has a safe space
to discuss things
if he wants to i tried to have a
conversation with him or rather i tried
to open the door to have the
conversation with him about this gender
disappointment because he actually
admitted to me that he was going to be
disappointed before we knew what the
gender was he admitted to me that he was
going to be disappointed if it was a
little boy
we went on a road trip this past weekend
and i my first question to him was do
you have the capacity to
discuss
gender disappointment on this trip he
said he hadn't really even had a chance
to process it yet
my husband's really good at
kind of just pushing it back
and not processing it
and it's
i mean i do it too by all means i've
just learned over the past couple years
through my counseling how to process it
a little sooner and and go from there
and i'm a little concerned that he's not
going
to be able to process it the way that he
needs to and i just don't want him to
hold on to that disappointment
and i don't want it to sneak up on me
either every time i see a cute little
pink dress all right
so so a couple couple of things here one
is
um he's lucky to have you
and i would well let me back out so
ultimately here you guys created a
picture
that um pictures the positive way i can
say this okay and then i'll give you the
negative in a second
you created a picture of a life that had
a little boy and a little girl in it
right and
suddenly you start to dress that picture
up figuratively and literally right you
put clothes on that picture you put
little adventures on that picture you
put hugs on that picture all those
things
and then if you're like me you can i can
fast forward 20 years real fast
right like me i'm going to sweat the guy
out at prom and i'm going to all those
things like that happen right i can i
can go away yeah husband was picturing
cleaning the guns
yeah all that fun stuff right so we can
do that
um
the not nice way to say that is y'all
created a fantasy
that wasn't real and now
what you have permission to do if
permission granting is something i can
do on a podcast you're allowed to be sad
about it just be sad about it like we
thought it was going to look like this
and it's not and we're actually it's
going to sound like a harsh word we're
going to grieve it
we're going to
openly state outside state out loud we
wanted this to be the case and it's not
if you don't your body will continue to
try to solve for that picture that
original picture that you painted
together
and the person who will bear the weight
of that will be your new baby boy your
son
right and that's what i'm worried about
so here's a couple of things
these were the plans were a fantasy but
there were plans nonetheless so what i
want you all to do is
this idea like well i haven't really
processed it yet you're not going to
unless you start speaking about it
though you've heard me say a million
times grief demands a witness you got to
say it out loud in front of somebody
else
and so i would love for you to and this
is going to sound ridiculous this isn't
a funeral
but i would love for you all to have
some sort of marker ceremony where you
speak out loud
even if it starts with you telling him
hey i talked to this guy and he said
we're allowed to be sad for a minute
we're allowed to be bummed out about it
and by the way you might be 25
um
your son might be 25
and you walk and see a girl in a cute
dress
and you're like i never had a daughter
that might always be there it's not a
bad thing you don't need to avoid that
by trying to avoid it you're gonna end
up cutting yourself off from your
friends that have little girls you're
gonna end up being annoyed when your son
brings home a little girl and wondering
why right so acknowledge it yeah man
that would have been awesome i don't
have that
and then be on about your day you hear
what i'm saying
i would love for you to have some sort
of ceremony that says all right we're
gonna go on a road trip together we're
gonna get some time together we're gonna
sit down and be honest with each other
about how we feel this thing hurts this
is hard i had a picture of this and then
in short order and this is important you
all have to be about making a new
picture with this little boy like you're
doing and you got to do that together
okay and i would push him on this your
husband until he tells you the words i
can't handle this right now please stop
i would say i want to have this
conversation
and i you go first setting the rules
we're allowed to say that we're sad
we're allowed to say we're pissed off
we're allowed to say we're frustrated
we're allowed to be upset at our little
boy for not being what we wanted we were
allowed to do that and then we're going
to put a pin at the end we're going to
put a period in that sentence and we're
going to start writing something new is
that fair
yeah absolutely cool
uh one other thing
i would stop using the phrase gender
disappointment
here's why okay
it sounds really close to some sort of
diagnostic
like i've got anxiety i've got
depression we are
together we have gender disappointment
as though this thing is happening to you
does that make sense
yeah i would rather it be less of a
thing like less of a pinstagram or
instagram
an instagram or pinteresty kind of word
i'd rather just be yeah we're super
bummed out
and when you say we're super bummed out
we're choosing to be sad for a season
your body takes ownership of that you
take ownership of that and it's not some
thing that's descending upon you like i
have a thing nah you don't you're just
sad man i'm bummed out i want to have a
daughter and i have a son now
and
uh
i wanted my kids in the order like i i
had drew it up that way and i got lucky
but i will tell you my heart was beaten
when when my we went to the first
sonogram with my son like is this good
like right so i kind of built it up and
i and i was like uh and it worked out
for me it ended up that we rolled the
dice and it worked out well and
sometimes it doesn't so i think it's
just owning that and then saying okay
here's what comes next but um if you
please please do me one favor don't feel
guilty about being sad is that cool
yeah absolutely have you felt that
i have um
it's more of i'm assuming it
ends up being the same but it's more of
i'm afraid that i'm gonna
treat this pregnancy
differently or the
you know the outcome
differently because i secretly wanted
or not so secretly wanted a girl versus
a boy and i know that that's not fair to
my unborn son i want to give him every
opportunity
that
my first son charlie
has and had yeah and i think you will i
i think the important thing is to shift
the disappointment towards the fantasy
towards the picture y'all had not
towards the kid
and that's that's the marker there so we
had this picture it's not gonna happen
i'm gonna be bummed out about that
and now we're gonna create something new
and i'm gonna look at this little
knucklehead and just be
completely in love with this ball of
chaos that's coming our way
but again all that starts with being
honest with yourself saying it out loud
owning it and then being able to say
okay what comes next what are we going
to do next but man jenny for whatever
it's worth you're right where you need
to be and you're both little boys are
going to be lucky to have you and your
husband's lucky to have you
um let me know when he's born send us a
photo can't wait to can't wait to cheer
you on then we'll be right back
hey dr john dolone here let's talk about
sleep my friends it's one of the best
things you can do to improve your mental
health and your physical health in one
of the biggest areas we neglect it's
time to change that and for me getting
good deep restorative sleep starts with
a good mattress that's why my family
sleeps on dreamcloud mattresses right
now dreamcloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for our listeners
499 bucks and accessories plus an
additional 250 cash discount that's like
740
in accessories and savings pillows
mattress protector luxury sheets all of
it it's time to get the rest your body
and mind needs because your mental
health
matters
this means prioritize your sleep it
means get seven to nine hours of sleep
each night that means ditching the 10
year old hand-me-down mattress that you
got from your weird aunt a long time ago
go to
dreamcloudsleep.comdreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get your
new mattress and enjoy your savings and
start sleeping today
all right let's go to
uh let's see nicole in kansas city
what's up nicole
hi dr john how are you doing just
started listening i just started
listening to your book this weekend
it's amazing it's awesome you think so
really that makes me happy yes hey and
it's making me happy when it's right
when this call is over if you will just
uh dm me your venmo and i'll send you
some cash for saying that i'm really
great oh my gosh that's so nice you
don't need to do that but i appreciate
it i don't even know how the no works i
really can't do that but i'd sound it
cool
so hey what's up how can i help all
right so i um i'm a divorced mom of two
awesome kids um my nine-year-old
daughter um has been diagnosed with with
adhd um she's also been diagnosed with
oppositional defiant disorder which i i
know is controversial but the fact is
that she actively
defies me if the default answer is no on
everything um and she
rejects anything that's important to me
you know and so you know if if it's
something that i i like or i want to do
it's going to be a no automatically um
give me an example
um
so you know even just like let's go to
the zoo today
no i don't want to go to the zoo today
i mean it's just everything is a default
no but my question that brings me to my
question so i am um in a relationship
now you know i'm dating someone um and
well i shouldn't say dating i'm in a
relationship and we've been together for
some time now um you all need to have
the dtr you need to define this
relationship yeah well it is defined
we're in a relationship and
you know i introduced my kids
early on in the relationship i
introduced my kids to
this
man and
they um you know i didn't introduce him
as a boyfriend right away you know just
we just kind of hung out in a park a
couple times
and uh you know went to like steak and
shake um but
you know at the time my very very
jealous ex-husband freaked out um and so
it sort of set me into a spiral of you
know this is too early i should be doing
this you know and um then covet came and
the truth is
you know it's been about 18 months now
i'm still in this relationship
and
my my daughter i've now now told her
that i have a boyfriend and she is angry
you know and she um
tells me all the time it's now becoming
like a part of
what she
brings up when she's upset so you know
if i make her mad in some way if i give
if i place a boundary or use some
discipline you know that the line is you
know i hate i hate you
you shouldn't be with this boyfriend you
know um you know i i don't like you i
don't like him and you know i i don't
ever want to be around him
and it's really holding me back from
i feel like i'm living two lives in a
lot of ways where i have this
life where i'm in a relationship and
it's very good and it's very solid and
then i have a separate life when i'm
with my kids
and um i'm feeling really stuck and so i
would love some advice on how to
move forward uh you got it man thank you
so much for
so clearly laying this all out that's
really helpful
um all right so i'm gonna you
we could have had we could have a whole
show just pulling this one call apart
okay yeah you got several things here
um so i'm gonna throw a lot at you you
stop me if you want me to to dig into
things okay and i was just feverishly
taking notes while you were talking here
um
okay so i want to back out to odd yeah
you know me and adhd okay
um
the
the
most compelling argument i've read both
physiologically and psychologically is
that
those two disorders if you will if you
want to call them that
are a
combination of of you know uh genetics
and combination of experience whatever
it's a body's response to chaos
okay yeah so you see that a lot in
divorced families
if kids because there was something
leading up to the divorce too right i
mean there was a season leading up to
yes and so that's that's the thing it's
like she's been this has been her way of
being her whole life you know long
before the divorce right right so i hear
that i hear that so here
i don't want you to
go in the mirror and be like i ruined my
kid and all that's not gonna help
anybody okay
it's just saying okay i'm i'm gonna let
adhd and odd and whatever other labels
somebody wants to throw at your kid
that's fine
that's a context not an excuse for how
we're gonna treat one another how we're
going to live in this house how we're
gonna do life together okay
and so um the way i explain it to my son
as and i'm a guy who's my adhd is
comical it's it's off the charts so it's
ridiculous
um so what does that mean that means i
have to set up systems so that
it doesn't give me a pass on showing up
to work on time i'm treating people with
respect on being kind being prepared
it's i don't get a pass on that i just
have to do more work than the average
person to get ready for some stuff i got
to set alarms when i sit down to talk to
my kids in the morning so that i don't
miss
um like when i need to leave so that i
can be on time for my recording right or
to be on air or whatever the thing is
and so i just have to create a new life
and that's fine everyone's got their
stuff
but often when we have young kids
especially kids of divorce that are
really acting out hard or they're really
struggling with focus and attention or
they just sit in the back of a room and
they disappear
we we tend to lean into they've already
had enough they've been through enough
like let's just let this thing pass or
this pass
and here's what a kid is screaming for a
couple of things number one one of the
most common child fantasies is that my
mom and dad are going to get back
together
if i can just get them to see me in the
right way
some kids double down on making straight
a's they become the perfect kid they're
trying to they think they were the
problem
other kids say can you see me can you
see me can you see me and that looks
like i'm screaming i'm yelling i'm
banging my head against the wall
ultimately there's this fantasy of where
we're getting back together
if it was possible which it might not be
i would love
a conversation now that your daughter's
nine with you and your ex-husband and
her
to say we still respect each other um
i'm dating somebody is your husband is
your ex dating somebody
yeah okay we are we still respect each
other you're still our baby girl you're
still the number one in our lives
when it comes to our kid i mean you're
still so important
let her know there's there's a period in
of y'all's relationship sentence right
we're moving on here that may not be
possible not all ex are that mature and
that grown up but that would be a gift
to your child it will hurt and it'll be
a mess and it will cause kicking and
screaming whatever but it will allow her
to begin to toggle out of
if i just do something they'll get back
together
and that leads me to
you mom are giving way
too much power to this nine-year-old
yeah that's what my therapist says too
well listen
here's it's not only when i say you're
giving her too much power you are but
that's not about you
she can't handle the weight of what
she's trying to carry around
because she's not yeah
and she's heartbroken and she's her
brain is firing all over the place right
she's got some she's got some true
neurological struggles right now or
psychological struggles or both and so i
would begin to in short order really
reclaim the ownership of your home
what does that look like when your child
says um i wrote this down here um i hate
you
number one she doesn't she doesn't have
words for i'm i my body reacts when you
come in the room because i feel like i
screwed something up like i broke up my
family like i'm none and they didn't
love me enough to stay together all
those things are overwhelming her nine
year little brain
and it comes out i hate you that's the
only language she has
a response to that is i'm so grateful
that you
felt brave enough to share that with me
we don't use the word hate in this home
but you are welcome to not like me right
now and i
and you're allowed to do that so thank
you for sharing that
and here's what she's finding
she is not responsible for mom's
emotional regulation
and if she can get you off kilter then
she has the power in your home and if
you flip that on its head she feels
responsible for how mom is doing
how mom feels and she cannot carry that
weight it's too much yeah
and so taking the sting out of i hate
you you just know this just hear me say
it she doesn't hate you she loves you
she just doesn't know what's happening
in her body
so cool and does she weaponize it does
she all over dad like he's the best he's
the greatest the whatever yes oh yeah
yeah she loves dad she loves dad's new
girlfriend oh the best she's awesome she
talks about the new girlfriend all the
time you know and then it's like she
hates
hates me hates my boyfriend right now
you are not living your life for the
approval of a nine-year-old
oh yeah okay
you are
using your wisdom and your strength and
your grief
to parent this young child through a
really tough situation
um
some kids won't talk
i've continued to get messages back that
are really um they fill me up they're
awesome of parents whose kids wouldn't
talk to them either they were annoying
or they were like shut up mom i don't
talk to you whatever and they started
doing the the journal on the bed
i write a note to my kid and then they
write me back
and the feedback i'm getting is it's
phenomenal like it's such a comically
easy tool that parents didn't know about
kids won't say things sometimes but
they'll write them down and it may be i
hate you i hate you i hate you you're an
idiot i hate your boyfriend
the response is thank you so much for
sharing that with me he's a really great
guy and i look forward to the day that
you feel safe around him
and leaving it at that and it's gonna
slowly take the sting out of that stuff
and she's going to realize this isn't
working and mom still loves me
and
i can't punish my mom because my mom's a
grown up and it's not allowing me a
nine-year-old to punish her right
um and you just you know this it's just
gonna be a y'all have a road to ho man
you're gonna have a young daughter
that's gonna be constantly asking
herself what she did wrong and it's
gonna take some really wise parenting
co-parenting on you and your ex
to let her know she didn't do anything
wrong she's a lovely wonderful young
girl
um yeah and then man at some point you
got to bring your if that's this guy's
going to be part of your life going
forward your daughter feels that gap she
feels that there's two moms too
yeah a mom that's getting dressed to go
out who's excited to let the that let
the
burden of this whiny nine-year-old in
this chaos of a house go so i can just
go out to eat and be with another
grown-up who actually likes me and she
feels that and so there's there's gotta
be some sort of hey he's going to come
you are welcome to join us for dinner
you don't have to say anything
and after dinner then you can go film
watch something or whatever go play some
games or whatever um but i'm going to
set the boundaries here and here's one
quick trick with some a kid who
struggles with oppositional divine
disorder
um it's just funny i may have talked
about this on the show or not
my wife was talking with a we're at a
parent-teacher conference and my son
doesn't have that but we were talking
about discipline and
i think it's called conscious discipline
environment it's it's a it's an
educational technique
okay but they were discussing it with
each other so it was my wife who's the
scholar and was sitting down with a
teacher and they were talking about um
how they do discipline
and i i i was listening to explain it
back and forth and finally i stopped and
i looked at my wife and said you do this
to me
and she smiled real big and it's like
yeah i do
so here's here it is
it is giving this child a framed sense
of ownership
so when instead of saying hey we're
going to the zoo today is that going to
be great then no
you suck i hate you we're not going to
the zoo who's the worst
um
it is here's three options
and one of the options can be ridiculous
we can sit outside in the yard and do
nothing that can be one of them
or we can go to a movie or we can go to
the zoo
you get to pick i'll give you 15 minutes
and i'll put on your favorite music
while you decide
and then there's this sense of
that's what i'm talking about i'll tell
you what we're going to do today right
and there's a
a sense of ownership and really you
framed the whole thing up yeah that
makes sense yeah although it does lose
my other child in the mix but i mean
that's a whole nother conversation
or this time you get to pick next time
um you're the other chagas to pick or
you all get to work on this together and
if you all don't come up with something
in 15 minutes i'm picking and i'm gonna
pick that we're just gonna go eat
broccoli at a local restaurant right i'm
gonna pick something ridiculous but
we're gonna let that nine-year-old
choose let those kids own it and then
you win because what you want is great
fun time with your kids and you'll get
that yeah and they will go with their
head the heads held high and their chest
puffed out a little bit there may be
some you can't make i'm not doing any of
this stuff you can't make me do any of
it and then you can say yeah we are
you're coming with us because you're
nine and i'm just bigger than you right
and you don't ever want to resort to
that sort of power but um sometimes you
have to with
she's always nine-year-olds but here's
what we're having we're just gonna take
that that weight off of your kid she's
not running the show anymore and maybe
you even sit down with your
nine-year-old depending on how
articulate how much she can understand
take her out to breakfast and say
it's been a hard few years and you've
had to own a lot of what's going on in
here
so i'm gonna start
um i'm gonna take ownership back of the
house you're my little girl and you have
a special place in my house this house
doesn't work without you i love you so
much
and so i'm gonna start picking up some
of the slack that i've let you have and
here's a couple of the rules we're not
gonna say hate in this house if you say
the word hate then you're choosing to
fill in the blank consequence and i hate
that i don't oh actually i just said
hate um i don't like that um i don't
want you to choose those things because
i want you with us and i want you fully
involved right um but those those
annoying things we're not going to say
bad words in the house um that's just
not how we talk to one another here we
treat each other with dignity respect
you can be sad and frustrated all you
want that's great um but you're not
going to use ugly words and you're not
going to say bad words in the house and
and so on and so forth right all that to
say is
it's a mess
growing up and dating and
making
you know secondary families and kids the
whole thing's a mess
retain that ownership of that home and
let your daughter know i see you and i
hear you and you are allowed to have
your feelings
they're okay
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better help online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we are back and for this third
call um let's let everybody know this is
a tough one this is a tough one um kelly
let me know about this call coming so i
could sit down and
um
meet with an expert just to make sure
um
unfortunately i've had too many of these
conversations i want to make sure i i
hit the nail on the head on this one um
this one's too important and too hard
uh so i'm gonna turn it over to tom in
chicago he can walk us through what's
been going on hey tom what's up man
oh we're hanging in there good deal so
um kelly uh sent me a note ahead of time
on this call so i could sit down with an
expert which i spent some time with to
make sure that i was able to serve you
guys the best we can
um
but i wanna hear your story just um as
as much as you feel that you can share
with us and we'll go from there
sure um so yeah thanks for talking with
us so we found out a few weeks ago that
a extended relative has been
sexually molesting our six-year-old
daughter
um that person has now been arrested so
our question for you is what
what does the next
days weeks months years look like for
our daughter and how can we best help us
oh man so welcome me back how'd y'all
figure number one i
i mean this is every parent's worst
nightmare right and
i guess as the father of a six-year-old
girl my heart's broken for you and
um
i'd hug you if you were sitting here so
just from
your city to my city know that i love
you and i'm sorry this happened um
jeez so
how how did y'all what with you how you
found out what's what's happened since
then
yeah the short version was my wife um
observed it in action
and observed what was happening
um we found out it's been going on for
several months
and then we
involved the authorities at that point
and then good for you
thank you good for you man
yeah there's been there has been some
negative feedback from other family
members on that yeah we'll screw them
they don't get a vote
yeah forget them if you ever doubt that
once just call me and i'll just say
screw them they don't get a vote
thank you the worst
absolute the worst unbelievable
it's disgusting and hey i hate the fact
i'd hate everything about this man so um
did y'all so your wife witnesses this
obviously she i'm assuming she flew into
a rage and stopped everything
um
not a rage she pulled the kids out of
the situation
because our younger son was there at the
time it was a
probably fairly typical of these sort of
situations where they were sitting on a
chair yeah and watching a you know
perfectly fine video and
the person put his hands down inside
her pants yep um so she separated them
started talking to people and our
daughter after a little bit did say you
know guesses have been happening
they've been going on for a while yeah
and then
my wife talked to the person
who after lying did say yes it did
happen
um at that point my wife removed
everyone from the home that the family
member's home and then um
we came home or she came home we talked
about who we call involved involve the
authorities at that point
gotcha
well man i am
so proud of you all for listening to
your daughter
and believing your daughter obviously
your wife saw this and for calling the
police um that already is step one
towards healing
okay
um did y'all go through
the rigamaroo the forensic interview the
nurse examinations y'all go through all
that
yes yeah that happened within a few days
afterwards and then there was no
nothing else
physically she's fine
okay um for people who
don't know
when you call the police they'll not
they'll normally go to a forensic
interview or somebody some sort of
psychologist or sometimes a detective
will
um walk through an interview sometimes
it's done in play therapy sometimes it's
done
in a really not great way um just in an
office with big fluorescent lights and
it's really scary and intimidating for a
six-year-old but that's when they really
dig in and get to the bottom what
happened and then there's often a
nurse's examination which is a really
invasive but very important um physical
examination to see if there's any you
know
any tearing any any sort of physical
um uh
issues here right
um and here's what i'll tell you that
feels like you can exhale a tiny bit
when those things are over
um i don't want you to underestimate
what a huge
shape-shifter impact that was for your
daughter
okay
those things sometimes come up 15 or 20
years later when she breaks her arm and
needs to go to the doctor and she won't
go
or when she's struggling with anxiety
and won't go talk to a counselor because
the whole process feels like
it's all wrapped up into this one thing
you know what i'm saying right okay
so what has been the next steps have you
all called somebody have you all started
talking to somebody what's been the next
steps or is it just kind of been a
freeze moment
um a little bit initial is the freeze
moment um
we you know just kind of we had to
uh yeah freeze from that point and then
we started talking we've talked our
pastor and his wife who've been very
helpful
some other close friends and then we
have talked to a couple different
counselors okay
been very helpful from their different
points of views
um the real thing we've been dialing
down on which our pastor gave us this
device is really just work on connecting
with
our kids okay um you know not not
specifically our daughter but both of
them yeah
um all right i'm gonna be real
straightforward here okay
and i'm assuming you're a pastor so
you're a person of faith
yes all right so i'm speaking as um
somebody on your team i'm person to
faith too okay not
a big chunk of our listeners aren't
that's fine i i want you to hear that
i'm not coming at you but i'm saying
this sitting on the pew next to you okay
um i'm actually not gonna give you the
ins and outs of what to do with your
daughter
here's why
this is not a moment for armchair
quarterback in this thing
this isn't a moment for googling this is
not a moment for pastors this is not a
moment for guidance counselors this
isn't a moment for asking people their
quote unquote wisdom
this is a stop the presses find a
trauma-focused cognitive behavioral
therapist a tfcbt therapist in your
community
and work a plan
and there's plans called seeking safety
there's some really extraordinary
processes with a trained professional
what i don't want you to do is to think
we can just do some things
and then it will be cool and we'll just
keep checking in with such and such your
pastor actually gave you some great
advice which is rarely the case these
days unfortunately
you got some great advice connection's
important
but that is
that's at the periphery okay
that is like if you think of a of
somebody who's scuba diving and they
need oxygen and then they need the tank
and then they need the boat
your pastor just told you to put gas in
the boat right
it's peripheral to the person at the
bottom of the ocean right now okay
um
your daughter over time with a therapist
is gonna here's what she's gonna relearn
she's gonna
what good touches
what safety feels like
that a a despicable evil thing happened
to her but she's not despicable or evil
that somebody committed a great shameful
evil act against her but she's not
shameful her body's not shameful
sexual intimacy when she's married in
down the road is not shameful
and somebody's gonna have to walk her
through this and she is six
okay
here's what that looks like they're
gonna teach her body to
not spin up on her when somebody begins
to invade her space and there's just a
process to that what i'll tell you is on
the back end of the process
the healing rate is is really
extraordinary it's pretty it's it's
actually it's unbelievable if you get
with the right person
teaching a six-year-old how to reclaim
autonomy of their body after someone has
taken it from them particularly somebody
that they trusted it's just hard
it's hard
and so um i'm not one of bad mouth
preachers i don't want a bad mouth i'm
not doing that i'm just saying this is
one of those moments you don't try to
change the oil in your driveway on this
one you go to a
the dealer mechanic on this one and get
the right work done okay
um
here's the
some people will say i don't have people
in my area
i don't have
whatever
then you drive
you figure it out um somebody works goes
to part-time for a year or six months
and we drive or we get hotel and we
figure this thing out this is really
hard okay um here's the second or third
or i don't even know what number we're
on here um
inside your house
when your kid talks about this has she
brought it up ever has it come up
no um
no not really she's talked about the
person who did it um and not in the not
in a negative context but more like hey
i'd like to go do this with this person
or they used to do this with me yes
okay i'm gonna tell you some really hard
stuff right now okay
one of the great evils of
sexual abuse with children
is being able to
toggle apart to pull apart that felt
good
with this was wrong
you know what i mean
is this it's um when you the first time
i heard an eight-year-old say
explain to me how she liked what was
happening i got like that was one of the
only times i've ever felt close to
physically vomiting in a conversation
with a kid it was it's brutal okay
and so yes there's gonna be this weird
hey can i go back and see
because i don't fully grasp the depth of
what has happened to me right
right and
so you here's an important thing i need
you to put in your back pocket and your
wife and anybody else you trust and love
with your kid
conversations will come up over time
and
anything other
you don't this is not for fixing your
kid
you can't fix anything here what we're
looking for is i want you to say i see
you i hear you
so when it comes up did you know that
this happened to me
do you remember when so and so did x and
y and z
the response is not a list of
things we've googled or that we've got
from somebody this it is
i'm so so sorry that happened to you
that should not have happened to you and
i love you
that's the answer right so we're always
going with i see you and i hear you and
your feelings are valid and what you
remember is valid i believe you not i'm
gonna fix this right now in this
conversation because what she's doing
now is she's re-practicing safety who's
safe
and the person who tries to dump a bunch
of info on her a bunch of facts and this
and this and this into that six-year-old
seven-year-old nine-year-old 15 year old
little brain
is not safe okay
safe is i see you okay and here's
another heavy one that i see a lot
if you or your wife or your family
members break down when this
conversation comes up which it will
or when she says hey i want to go see so
and so i'm going to go see uncle whoever
or what whoever
and you go
either you break down crying or you fly
off into rage or whatever the that that
over emotion is what she's gonna quickly
learn to do is to help you emotionally
regulate yourself
and that's not her job
okay
so it there is feeling sad and there's
feeling heartbroken and they're letting
her know i choose to be angry about this
because that shouldn't have happened to
you
or what happened to you was wrong and
that shouldn't happen you are too
precious and too wonderful and too
important and too brilliant and too
too beautiful and too strong
should never have happened to you
there's a difference between that and
just a fit of weeping and rage and you
might have the rage you might have the
weeping i sure would um i'm gonna
have my extreme moments with my
counselor okay i'm gonna have my extreme
moments with my group of guys that i
meet with on a regular basis those guys
can handle the weight of my friendship
in those moments a six and nine-year-old
can't what i don't want a nine-year-old
doing is saying if i talk about this it
makes daddy really sad and so i'm just
not going to talk about it because i
love daddy i don't want to be the one
making him sad you see how that math
works for a kid
and so it's that balance of you don't
want to be a robot you want him to know
what noise this made me sad and i'm
choosing to have my heart broken here
all those things
and
i'm still in control of my body i'm
still controlling my feelings and
emotion in this house
um
here's the last thing i'll ask you
um without getting in detail about the
family member
how are you man
like somebody in your family hurt your
kid like that's a hard thing to make
peace with
yeah i don't i didn't really have any i
had more of the sadness motion just see
how the weight of the situation got any
of the anger rage it will come
it will come okay be ready for it
because it will come in waves okay
um have you had a chance is this your
family member or your wife family member
my wife um have you had a chance to talk
to the person
uh i had a short conversation with them
uh
an hour or two before they were arrested
when they were asking me not to call the
police
okay that's good
i would recommend
of all the things i've just told you
besides seeing your kid the second most
important recommendation is i would make
sure you are constantly writing things
down that you feel that you want to say
that come to mind i wish i could have
this phone call and they'll come more
and more over time
and um
when you are about to go to sentencing
and when the your daughter gets put on a
witness stand which you probably will
all those kind of things make sure
you've got a
legacy of writing this stuff out here's
why
and your wife too if you don't it
we call i call it leakage that's a gross
counseling word but it will find its way
out and it usually find its way out in a
real inopportune time that sometimes
makes you look foolish or you look like
an idiot
like you look like the problem when
you're not you're a dad who's beside
himself because somebody hurt your baby
you know what i'm saying
so this is constant i i i i would really
recommend you and your wife get somebody
to talk to
because there's going to be the guilt
and it was your family and i can't
believe i missed this all those things
are part of the healing process that the
whole film is going to undergo here and
having a
person that would walk through that with
you would be really important
um okay so i just threw a lot at you
here's what the next few months is going
to look like you ready drum roll i have
no idea okay i have no idea
um
i know that if you get your daughter
into
some sort of tfcbt treatment program
with a
therapist that you trust that's good
and you and your wife give her see her
and give her space and you're connected
with her
um and you let her have her feelings out
loud that the chances that she grows up
to be well and whole are very very very
good
okay um and
this will
this will
raise hell and her for years and years
and years to come it's the it's the evil
of sexual abuse and trauma
okay it's holding both of those things
very loosely right
anybody who tries to tell you well the
next two months is going to be like this
is just selling you something get away
from that person okay
don't take any outside counsel or
information and try to impose a
framework on how your daughter should be
healing right now how she should be
feeling her grief is hers and she
doesn't even know she's grieving yet
she misses special time with uncle
so-and-so
and that's so disgusting to even say out
loud but that's the reality of a
six-year-old right
um how's your marriage right now brother
um
as good as it's ever been it's this is
really that's it hasn't been
this is not creating any sort of stress
between us thankfully it's awesome and
um
good awesome
the temptation will be you all have been
really tight and having a lot of great
conversations and probably going on
walks and having moments of what do we
do now and all those kind of things that
can bring a couple together
please make sure you put a star on a day
on the calendar and you'll continue
having these at a regular intervals how
are you how are we how are we doing
how's things going are we going to go
out on a date tonight are we going to
continue to do life
okay
please make sure y'all continue that
thing moving forward
and again i don't it's not going to help
you i just need to say it out loud man
i'm sorry this happened
i'm sorry thank you that's
and by the way
call me anytime you need to tell me
you need me to tell you to screw them
sure any family member that is
there should be a race to the police
department
i'm going to call them no no no i'm
calling them let's call them together
that's the race
okay anybody who tells you well i don't
i just don't think we should press
charges or um are we sure anybody who
says that
is done
yeah got it
and that might be really hard it might
be your wife's parents
that might be her other siblings and
they are opting out of your life if they
if they make those suggestions
okay okay
i've got no quarter for that
nonsense it should be a group of people
rallying around
a
hurting six-year-old little girl not
trying to protect a
scumbag
gosh man somebody who's got a lot of
challenges anything i can help you else
with brother i feel like i talked at you
a lot anything i can help with ma'am
no i think that has been very helpful to
give us a pathway to what we should be
doing and get in touch with the right
counselors okay
um if you need something man please i'll
walk with you through this um holler at
me if you need anything
um
and just so for the general public we
are talking about creating some training
for pastors and what they say when
someone drops us on because they just
don't have that training and how what
would we say to
people who are just helpful friends and
neighbors and go-to folks in communities
what do you do what do you say when some
when a child drops us on you when a
parent comes to you um what do you say
or do and somebody in your family comes
to you and says hey i think one of our
family members is abusing children what
do you do at that point um so we may
come out with some trainings there um if
you have interest in that holler at me
because i think we're gonna need to get
on that there's just too much hurt going
on and too many people hurting kids and
then people the follow up the care that
happens right after that's just a mess
man
thank you so much tom for being brave
and for having the hard conversation and
big shout out to you and your wife for
staying connected during the season
and for loving that six-year-old little
girl
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back um
i think i was going to wrap the show up
here uh this is a hard one
um
don't hurt kids
don't hurt kids
love your babies
love your kids
if your kid's struggling
get them help they need
don't hurt kids
that's kind of all i got to say about
that so as we wrap up today's show
man
kelly
is a fangirl of australian uh boybandpop
hashtag didn't know that was a thing
and um it's what
it's not boy band pop it's like blues
they don't
trust me on this one
i'm trusting kelly on this one it's not
boy band pop it's blues
it's the teske brothers that it is i'm
gonna rock them when it's over it's the
tuskegee brothers and the song called
rain and it goes like this
[Music]
let's read the lyrics here
[Music]
yeah is that rain or are you crying
again
that's a good line would it be the same
if i could hold you my friend i know
it's hard to be alone a soul with no
face it's a lonely embrace but i know
it's hard i know it's hard to be alone
yeah
now there's clouds between us all in the
roading so clear but we can still walk
or crawl but i know it's hard to be
alone
it's hard to be alone
luckily for you you're not alone we'll
see you soon
coming up on the next episode
number one book in the nation built
non-fiction we crushed it i've never
been number one at anything we all have
that one friend though that would prefer
to listen to the man with 17 youtube
followers out of the trunk of his car
with a mobile phone microphone going ah
guess what everybody i figured it out
listen to this we all have that friend
my friend
happens to be
rachel cruz okay let me say this i love
conspiracy theories okay yes i'm not
like i haven't written books like i'm
not all like what's in my head and the
reason she doesn't write them down
because then they'll know
that's why
you